bienvenue sur diagonale tu es une leçon
aujourd'hui spécial philidor alors
l'ouverture fille dort avec jean
baptiste
bonjour jean baptiste bonjour stéphane
alors le vivre à tout le monde j'ai
divorcé c'est un vieux au début oui
aussi vieux que lui aussi vieux plus on
va rappeler qu'ils aient fini en hausse
était un musicien et puis on xviiie
siècle exactement ses pairs aussi été
musicien
ouais donc lui aussi donc à la cour de
louis saha ce que le 16 août 15 ou lui
15000 16 des deux fameux sans doute les
deux et donc il a écrit plusieurs
morceaux connus
or moi je dois vous trouverez tous
assurent sur internet sans problème
il s'appelait louis andré danican
philidor et c'était considéré comme à
l'époque le plus grand un joueur du
monde certainement et c'est le premier
qui a découvert la l'intérêt des pions
dans le jeu d'échecs du placement des
pions ouais en fait
bon c'est vrai qu'ils étaient considérés
comme je vois les plus fortes de son
époque même s'il est difficile à
l'époque de savoir qui est le plus fort
oui évidemment n'est pas les structures
actuelles en tout cas ce dont on est sûr
c'était un des premiers à avoir écrit de
la théorie oui sur les échecs l'analyse
du jeu d'échecs de philippe était très
importante a fait donc c'était un destin
des premiers à avoir remarqué des livres
des chèques de l'initiateur donc des
grottes théoricien actuelle voilà donc
qui finit d'or ce joueur du xviiie
siècle donc
à inventer notamment mais un début une
ouverture qui porte son nom qui par une
ouverture je dirais un peu
un peu tranquille me qu'il est pas
forcément il faut qui demande de la
précision
non c'est une ouverture qui revient
d'ailleurs à la mode qui est encore
aujourd'hui je pense largement
sous-estimée mais sur une ouverture qui
est tout à fait correct et qu'il est
employé maintenant par certains des
meilleurs joueurs du monde on peut citer
par exemple radjabov wii qui est un
joueur quand même extrêmement actif et
qui bizarrement emploie aussi la fidi
d'or maintenant de plus en plus ça
prouve que c'est une voiture qui tient
la route on peut citer aussi notre
français je crois un christian bauer
question spécialistes et s'en vouloir
qu'à un spécialiste puisqu'il a écrit un
livre your mais au moins tout cas au
moins un en france est en tout cas oui
c'est suffisamment rare pour être dit
donc c'est un en tout cas grâce à une
maison d'édition française on a réussi à
avoir rallié en français sur la fille
leader et puis etienne bacrot a
également joué la fille qui dort pas mal
de fois pendant une période
on va rentrer assez précise de la philly
d'or et je vais pas toutes les variantes
donc voilà ça revient à la mode on peut
citer aussi une discipline où le fort ce
soir romain qui joue souvent ça est très
fort je me fais donc on va voir cette
ouverture philidor donc qui date du
xviiie siècle
inventé par notre grand illustre
français et joueur français louis andré
danican philidor musiciens aussi dont
4,4 première chose qu'il faut dire sur
la fil d'or c'est qu'on peut l'atteindre
par d autres de coups différents bien
sûr alors il ya l'ordre de coûts avec
1,5
bien sûr voilà avec celle tout à fait eu
4 5 donc là on part du principe qu'un
miroir une autre chose en tout cas
validé trois cavalières 3 on attaque le
pion et 5 donc ça c'est le ouverture
légère la plus usitée un asile sur des
cils et des six voilà donc c'est sa
seule philidor tout de suite déjà déjà
on est dans la fidi dehors après il
faudra y est on va voir les variantes
mais c'est déjà ce coût des six qui
symbolisa donc on verrouille la case de
par contre on a un problème avec le
fouet suit pas sortir
ni ans et 5 rbds et 4 donc il ya un peu
bouché mais on va voir si pas forcément
un gros un gros souci d 4d 4 et là déjà
alors là il ya plusieurs choix soit soit
on prend voilà soit on prend des 4 11 et
l'autre soit on joue le coup calais 17
s'était pas exactement la fille leaders
tels que notre ancêtre l'avait imaginé
ouais il soit en tout cas et 17 là
c'était plutôt cette position là voilà
alors l'idée pourquoi calais 17 parce
qu'en fait bon la menace des blancs
c'est quand même de prendre répond aussi
un conte prend 1,5 et après la prise
on échange les dames et on gobe le pion
aux cinq ans donc il faut alors le coup
est ce que le coup cavaliers si c'est
possible oui c'est aussi possible parce
qu'on contre attaque ici sur le sol
indien
c'est une possibilité d'ailleurs ici le
plus simple est de jouer cavalier ses
trois simples calais on retombe après
calais 17 dans des ventes de philidor
entendre la précarité semana vente
classique donc qu'il faut il faut
connaître ces sept on verra on verra
cette position alors qu'est ce qu'on va
regarder je prends des cas de prime
abord on regarde d'abord reprendre des
quatre banques et finalement une prise
simple donc il faut quand même connaître
ça mais là on propose de reprendre
simplement que lecavalier qu'elle allait
prendre des quatre voies la comprendre
et la dame c'est aussi une possibilité
mais bon aussi pendant qu'alain cavalier
prend des quatre et plus un cavalier f6
qu'allié c3 et c3 protège le team car
bien sûr et fos est donc un
développement rapide et simple
finalement des noirs c'est une ouverture
qui est vraiment simple limpide et cas
limites ne pose pas de problème les noix
en développement sain juste un petit
problème ce fou qui doute un peu sur le
toit qui se développe vite pour pouvoir
réaliser le plus tôt possible
la poussée des seins poussée des seins
nus sur cd 5 poursuit égaliser au centre
donc là on a deux variantes disons
on vous laisse rouler choisir on va dire
la variante tranquille
la variante un peu plus brute elle la
vend brutasse il faut s car c'est faux
f4 et sur petit rock
alors là on a la possibilité et
éventuellement de jouer dan d2 aussi
voilà avec lizeroux grand roque faire le
gang de ce côté là avec les vite avec
l'idf 3g kanata celle à trois et ensuite
on a taclé le rock et demi par gironde
et recomposées ceux qui sont habitués
aux leçons de débats tv peuvent avoir
déjà quelques petites ficelles pour la
taxe de rock opposé tout à fait donc
petit rock
on peut aussi jouer faux aux deux
fenêtres toutes les possibilités
voilà un peu plus un peu plus tranquille
matin avec eux donc petit rock dam des
deux mètres et au centre et ses
ouvertures qui ma foi et bien réussi
autre variante que fo avec 4 et le coup
j'ai trois alors autre variante le coup
j'ai 3 voilà g3 qui donc vise
directement la casse des crs des simples
on veut protéger puis 1,4 qui derrière
et le fou derrière contrôlera aussi la
casse des 5 1 alors là on va être très
clair si les noirs les sphères fou g2
ils sont verrouillés ils vont être
complètement étouffé voilà complètement
étouffé qui donc le seul coup ici pour
essayer de perturber un peu les blancs
c'est de jouer des saintes et saint tout
de suite profité de l'affaiblissement
des diagonales blanche en a joué deux
fois le cou noir mais on profite du fait
que les blancs ont saisi un coup de
pioche ont joué un coup de pied j'ai
toujours parlé dans le pion de philidor
là c'est une histoire de coups de pions
donc là la prise au centre simplifie
totalement la position
donc il faut jouer l'autre coup si on
veut garder l'attention qui est le coût
de 5
le cénacle qualifie donc cavalier g4 les
g4 non pas en 17 matchs et 4 on a
d'ailleurs le contrôle à pied
de la place de 6 et alors là en fait on
est un tout petit peu embêté avec les
blancs si on essaie de s'accrocher au
plus haut de cinq donc on va vous
simplifier la vie est rentré dans la
grande ligne qui est très bonne pour les
blancs en tout cas qui ne présente aucun
risque
c'est fou j'ai deux en fait qu'est-ce
qu'on peut pas tenter un coup comme e6
aussi j'ai envie de tout de suite parce
que si l'idée c'est que j'ai intercepte
le fou c'est 8 et le cabba et g4 et ont
pris une bonne question ça fait aussi
partie de la théorie mais en fait c'est
pas si terrible en fait on remet le
cavalier en six mois là et on n'a pas
peur d'être des rockets puisqu'après
droit preuve cette on peut faire un roc
artificiellement le taux refi dr 8 et
remettre le ronge et 8 et apprend mais
le range et on n'a pas de problème
puisque le pion des cinq empêche tout
échec sur ses gonds et hand-ball
consolidé avec ses six enfants ont tous
joué à millas donc donc à connaître
quand même à connaître à leurs pieds oui
bien sûr donc alors aussi se pose pas de
problème donc l'idée plutôt site je
continue le développement fut j'ai deux
projets de laisser tomber ce pion cinq
ans fait son fait 1,3 qu'on échange de
plus de 50 l'option de dessin gagne une
autre manière donc cavalli prend 1,5
voilà il a honte de prendre toujours
pâle qui ont des enfants mais on peut
encore placer des pièces avec grand dam
doum en grillant des temps bien sûr on
attaque le cavaly c'est un bruit parce
que si lecavalier s'en va on peut voir
caler prendre des cinq à prendre une
menace sur le fou et c'est bien sûr très
calme revient c'est 6 on prend ces 6
attention le karyu 5 et attaquer pallada
on peut pas prendre du plomb cavaliers
attaquer c'est l'heure ouais on prend
maintenant alors on pourrait se dire bon
la partie c'est égalisé il ya plus de
plus le centre de part et d'autre mais
les blancs conserve quand même un
avantage léger mais quand même un
avantage puisqu'ils ont des pièces qui
sont très bien placés notamment le
cavalier des cinq qui est une pièce
superbement installé au centre
donc pas fou aussi ce faux 6 là il faut
connaître aussi un pour le coup petit
rock voilà on n'a pas peur de vous
prendre et on va clouer se fout voilà
donc la présence de la perte de fou dans
une position si ouverte ce serait un
avantage on surfe apprendront des cinq
petit rock tour d un petit rock tour d
un voilà et là on a un problème sur la
dame niass cavaliers six échecs et gagne
jamais perdu bien sûr qu'il faut jouer
food et 6 par exemple voilà et la foulée
4 ou esclave pardon au f4
l'idée c'est que si les noirs prennent
on prend du cavalier et ensuite on
reprend la paire de faux la tomate
attaquer ensuite on prend le fou aussi
c'est on affaiblit la structure des
pions on a fait lui la structure et on
prendra sans doute le cavalier c6 avec
une faiblesse supplémentaire voire même
jour accordé sept buts au web on peut
garder ce fou parce que je fous est
vraiment très fort très fort mission
n'est pas pressé de prendre ce qu'elles
veulent pas pressé donc bonne position
donc voilà surprendre des 4 et prendre
des claques moi j'aurais tendance plutôt
à jouer avec jeu avec g3 avec g3 voilà
mais les amateurs de rock opposées
peuvent tenter le coup fourré f4 qui est
pas mal aussi
donc alors on va reprendre ces deux
possibilités sur 6,5 km 3 des 6 et 6 des
quatre on a vu si on prend des claques
maintenant on va voir l'autre variante
qui est calée 17 oui mais dans ces cas
là on va on va partir avec l'autre deux
coups alors l'autre ordre coup on va la
voir l'autre là que ça se permet
d'aborder là un autre façon on peut y
arriver aussi par eux quatre des six oui
voilà des cas là des quatre cavaliers f6
cavalière six attaques le pion 1,4 on
sort en 3 et 5 tout de suite voilà noir
n'ont pas peur de la prison qu'il n'en
ait son papa de la présence de cinq
puisque sur pions prend en fait
simplement plus on prend nos empreintes
d'un prendre dès maintenant des vides
reprendre d'élite fous ces quatre fous
ces quatre là il faut jouer roi 8 en 8
ou b4 plutôt faible et 4 mai 3,8 et une
possibilité aux 6-8 on peut aussi jouer
en 8 mois là et en fait on a
l'impression qu'a très bien puisqu'on se
venge sur le pion aux quatre ici le web
et on va jouer recettes on a
l'impression que le fait d'être
défroqués pose un problème en fait pas
du tout
la casse des 5es contrôle et contrôlable
en tout cas par le pion c'est alors que
la case des 4 et contrôlable par le pion
ces deux mais ce plan s'est débloquée
pour l'instant donc finalement c'est
vraiment pas grand-chose problème
voilà voilà donc ce n'est pas un
problème donc des quatre cavaliers cisco
blessés 3e 5 on n'a pas peur de la prise
ici donc à relief trois là par contre on
menace de gagner en scène d'où le coup
car les bd cette voie là et là on
recevoir la prise en d4 mais là c'est le
coup qui avait levé 17 et là on tombe
pendant que dans la position typiques de
philidor à leur rendre la grande halle à
rien si on est de mauvaise humeur
qu'est ce qu'on fait on joue comme on
comme shirov qui a initié le coup qu'on
va vous montrer
même si là c'est pas une partie de
chiroque augmente c'est une partie d'un
autre ex fait de l'échiquier qui
emelyanov way est excité et donc on nous
g4 vous ces quatre là mais ce récif ça
va plaire voilà qui va appeler un joueur
agressif c'est le coup de shirov alors
avec des habits lisez ce cavalier 6
voilà avec l'idée de jouer g5 et sur un
coup comme machiste par exemple eh bien
on jouerait h33 ouais on joue h3 et on
met le faux angers 2 c'est une sorte de
fientes kétou améliorer la même idée que
tu as leur manque à gagner du temps
parce que les noirs ont utilisé une fois
que le cavaliere 3 sera parti on jouera
f4 ainsi on aura une avalanche sur l
avalanche de pions filbet lacazette 55
cavaliers à cheval sur la position noir
séparément si les noirs prénoms des
quatre on prendre car il y en a très
belle occasion d un superbe
donc la question qu'on peut se poser
quand même sur g4 la moindre des choses
c'est de se demander ce qui se passe si
on accepte ça quelques pions avec
cavaliers projet l'association n'est pas
défendu et la dame lui ôterait contrôle
parce qu'il ya le travail f3000 sur une
fois il faut absolument regarder cavale
et pranger 4 que se passe-t-il
et bah tout simplement tour g1 tout
revient là il n'y a pas de meilleurs
coûts que de revenir pour revenir près
de tunis à son âge 3 va venir si vous
faites ça secret fils positionnelle
voilà c'est à dire qu'on va pas chercher
à regagner quelque chose tout de suite
en fin de droits tranquillement jouer
parce qu'on on mise sur la paralysie du
fouet fuite
il ne peut pas partir parce que sinon
pas venir un set puisque tout repeint en
blanc ces êtres reprennent le pion g7
avec un bénéfice d'activité et sur la
tour sera plus active
mais alors on pourrait pas jouer a tenté
de jouer avec g61 du côté noir sans
doute
ah oui mais ça paraît du temps aussi
perdre du temps mais on va voir comment
comment les noirs ont réagi dans cette
partie ces six ans la c6 d'am dam des
deux baies 5 et 5 1 classique dans la
fille d'edward cet ordre de cool way
l'idée c'est évidemment toujours pareil
on veut attaquer ici le câble et c3 et
après c'est le point 4 qui morfle donc
il faut faire quelque chose à trois et
un bon coup à droite un beau coup
souvent alors quand les tours sont en
face comme ça parce qu'on n'a pas peur
de l'a5 puisqu'on pourra pas jouer b4
tout de suite cause d'options promet 4.4
et tout reprendre tour où il ya un
clouage et un clouage donc on joue
d'abord foulée 7 qui peut menacer après
de jouer à 5-4 il faut d'abord
effectivement joué 17 donc maintenant
grand roque là donc ça c'est une
position hors c'est une position qui
ressemble un peu aussi à la pire qu'un
round te fais donc alors ici damas cinq
là passez moi par exemple donc ici et on
vous le toujours le profil à qui revient
très souvent quand il ya eu le cran
comme ça alors de la partie des médias
rohff a continué par b4 des 4 alors il
ya un échange en p4
alors il ya eu échange en d4
effectivement d'un parent b4 et
maintenant un échange sont parfois
j'aime bien comme les blancs ont joué
oued et prend 1,5
cavalli promet un vrai cavalier prend
1,5 des premiers simples et fo h3
fourrage trois superbes voilà alors
courage trois menaces de déroule 17-17
échec ou va loin puisque sur cavani
prend évidemment il ya dame prend 17
avec matt on peut pas jouer tour des
huit parce que il ya tour s'est reprise
voilà il ya les nyala tout ici est la
dame donc sur tour des huit durées
d'emprunt tour avec matt voilà et
finalement dans cette partie le retard
de développement des noirs vont finir
par lui coûter cher
fossey l'on voit quoi sacrifice g4 suivi
tour j'ai un fossé très vite pour donner
de l'air au roi en fait donc la foux 17
pour les échecs
alors imaginons il a pris d'abord à
winnipeg
pas de maths donc il peut prendre
beaucoup moins et puis juan suite d'un
échec
roy et fuite et la regarder bombay
effectivement bon mais il est blanc ont
un avantage puisque la tourache 8 joue
pas tout simplement jouer au roi trop
mal placé les tours sont pas liés cette
tour est atteint quand donc c'est bien
pour les blancs et le loup dame c7 est
très fort puisqu'on menacent à présent
de doubler les pièces lourdes sur la
septième rangée menace à la fois le pion
aux cem et de jouer tour 17 avec de tout
ramasser way pour amasser voilà dans ce
vivier de ce sacrifice avec g4 très joli
très très intéressant ce coup j'ai 80
sacrifices
à noter je le note je sais que tu prends
plein mais où il aidera la laj le tuer
parce qu'il a il me plaît il va les
leçons que l'on prépare je sais que tu
ressors avec des seins je sens que je
vais le jouer suis là parce que tu sais
que ça me rend service tu sais que j'ai
gagné des partis comme ça à je sais je
sais j'en ai même vu en direct en direct
alors câble et b17 alors
sous ces 4 est la possibilité la plus la
plus usitée en voilà ça c'est vraiment
suite la plus courante sur la défense
philidor alors il faut s est fausse et
qui font peut-être un bon devant leur
écran puisque c'est un sacrifice qui a
l'air intéressant comme ça s'il vous
prend à vii alors on pourrait se dire
oui bien sûr koupreïev cet échec
classique on apprend on va prendre un
g25 cavalli g5 ou adroit et oui ça c'est
un sacrifice qu'on retrouve parfois
enceinte ouverture qui a l'air
intéressant puisque la case e6 est
affaibli et au coup suivant le cavalier
va alors on peut pas aller en 8es pas
les 1/8 pourquoi parce que caprica le
site la dame est prise dans les modes la
dame et madame échec et mat mais y'a pas
des maths de la dame et on va la prendre
ton est en revanche avoir une dame de
plus a bien besoin
donc on peut pas non plus venir en fuite
pour la même raison qui aurait échec
pour connaître voilà donc a que deux cas
soit j'évite way qui est sans doute pas
le meilleur puisque le roi va boucher
quand même la tour soit plutôt justice
même si c'est dangereux
g6 disons qu'on n'aura pas peur trop de
passes que sur cavaliers
ensuite on jouera h cicero h7 c'est une
possibilité mais je mets mes roi g8 est
aussi possible alors voir roger vite on
va donc roi j'évite g8 est aussi
possible c'est moins dangereux pour le
roi qu'on joue quand même cavalier aussi
scaglia six des huit forcé et là hop
fourchette france et cette fourchette
dame jusque-là goze tout à l'air de très
bien se passer pour les blancs
exactement sauf qu'il ya d'objets 6,6 et
on va contre-attaquer en fait sur le
sujet de on est obligé de prendre la
tour sinon on a donné pour rien sinon à
dos les voit ainsi offert au kung fu bo
lui qu'on a donné une pièce dont quatre
comme réduire le crédit et voilà mais la
battant la contre attaque des noirs
arrivent d'un projet de d'un projet deux
ehpad autre coup que tout est fin prêt
là sinon la tour est perdu
et là maintenant il faut commencer à
penser à faire jouer notre notre tour et
on va jouer à chis comme tu préconises
et le tout à l'heure où tous âges 6
voilà le suivi de rouached 3,7 et on va
ramener la tour est en fait on
s'aperçoit que les blancs beaucoup de
mal à développer d'abord ils ont un
cavalier en a huit qui travaillent place
et s'ils perdent ce cavalier ce sera une
position perdue pour les blancs oui ça
fera deux pièces de pièces pour la
tournée sur parle même pas des pions tu
vas tomber ici il peut vous sortir tout
de suite ne peuvent le sortir mais la
taxe va aller très vite aussi par
exemple on imagine à coup comme fou et 3
portes et on peut aussi envisager en
piste même où lui 2 h 6 je le sais tu es
en train de voir pions prend des cas
parce que l'idée ce qu'on va venir avec
le caballero 5 et on a une très belle
case en f3 mais moi je préfère qu'on ne
tape pas trop vite on a droit à cette
possibilité de jouer le plus interpellé
on peut le faire plus tard et on fait
d'abord juillet la tour je pense que
c'est je pense que c'est plus
intéressant d'accord 1,6 voilà
hachey fait sur kouakou kung fu et 3 par
exemple imaginons que d'autres normales
mais on a cavaliers g4 et avec l'idée
est de prendre en h2 comme tout comme tu
voulais faire alors pour aller en 1 /
bien surprendre hd ou voire même prendre
une fois dans certaines classes et c'est
en fait une position qui a une mauvaise
réputation pour les premiers blancs donc
se fout ce sacrifice à la tan tan han f7
mais il faudra pas se laisser séduire
pas aussi beau final il faut savoir que
le grand maître israélien qui est très
bon théoricien les comme murray on
connaît bien pour ceux qui jouent à
paris puisqu'il est parisien depuis
longtemps ce jour sacrifices vous prend
à vii
il joue très bien mais alors c'est c'est
vraiment chaque fois sur le fil du
rasoir il a beaucoup beaucoup travaillé
donc je connais bien la position c'est
pas un sacrifice perdant mais c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu'on peut pas
conseiller à quelqu'un qui apprend les
ouvertures
donc petit rock et laura où le petit
rhône qu'il est sage
bien sûr ici kirk aussi le tir rock
aussi à autour d'un terrain donc je
consolidant le pion aux quatre puisque
des fois aussi il faut faire attention
il
il peut y avoir certaines variantes on
peut prendre quatre avaient été des cinq
possible quoique la tour e 1
ces six alors ça c'est classique ne la
finit de trek ou tranquille je contrôle
la casse des 5 c'est toujours utile je
peux envisager des des cinq plus tard
mais aussi surtout bcb 5 avec gain de
temps sur le fou suivi d'un fou bessette
puisque ce faux des problèmes pour
sortir foulée 7 et puis parfois on peut
prendre des quatre jouer c'est simple
c'est un peu comme dans la pire qu
expression sur l'album expression sur
les lames donc là on l'a le k4 hilal qui
claqua très bon alors là bon les noirs
n'ont pas envie de se désespérer ils
vont pas ils ont envie de rêver 5 alors
s'ils jouent à 6 par exemple
alors s'il joue ici à 6 voilà à 6 avec
des plus tard de m la tour en belgique
éventuellement et de jouer deux baies 5
ce serait une faute positionnelle un
jour à 5 et oui on joue à 5 est en fait
plus jamais jouer baissier souple et
simple sur une prise ici avec un
affaiblissement en prendra effectivement
le coup le coup b5 surprise en passant
et les plantes donc c'est complètement
c'est sur le coup à cinq est
envisageable
le ver le coup à cinq est envisageable
et d'ailleurs
il faut ans il faut en parler parce
qu'il ya une petite idée derrière le cou
dans le coup à cinq c'est de jouer
que ceux qui se battent bêtise d'un
système ses citoyens a bien joué et sur
à 50 jou h300 comme si c'est ici un
piège aurait donc sur à 5
on joue plutôt le coup sûr à 5
bonjour tout le courage trois là en fait
oui on joue on joue h3 pour éviter
cavaliers b6 suivi de fruges et 4 e à
l'efb et si je vous bougez et ensuite
fouillé quatre grandes pêcher cette
variante on joue avec moi là alors en
fait pourquoi le coup cavaliers b si ce
n'est pas possible tout de suite voilà
attaque le fou est fou et images et vous
éclaire les clés à travers à une
question sur le plan des quarts la voilà
la cause de fouet droit par exemple les
trois voies la foulée 4 et l'appui on
prend au sein et oui alors sur la prison
prend la dame et on prend le kyocera
corp souhaite ou au foot en f3 et on
donne donc la paire de faux sang rennes
la paire de fruits une compensation
voilà alors c'est pas l'idée du cloud
âge voilà le clouage c'est vraiment pour
embêter les blancs mais pas pour
échanger c'est pour embêter c'est pas
pour de faux bien sûr
alors donc à 4 donc ce qui propose de
préparer ce coup là ces dames c'est cet
homme c'est cet élan aux menaces
cavaliers b6 maintenant car il y signera
pas les changes de dames dans la
variante la prison vers ouaga en voilà
tout à fait fou j'ai quatre abattoirs
dont il faut pas oublier h3 là
maintenant faut pas oublier trop
imbriquées des idées comme ça caché dans
ses ouvertures qu'il faut absolument
connaître parce que la cab les décisions
je vous fous et il n'y a pas foule et 4
absolument c'est cette voie là mais
l'idée quand même pour revenir à cette
idée pour les noirs de jouer b5
c'est qu'ils vont s'y joue à 6 on a dit
il y avait à saint bien sûr alors ils
vont prendre leur temps ils vont meubler
6 fait six d'abord et après assises et
après à 6 et après mais ça pour éviter à
5 comme ça sur à cinq ans ou bien sûr à
5 baies 5
il n'y a pas la prison à 5 serait
stupide dont vous rêvez 5 on perd un
temps mais c'est utile voilà cela dit le
pion b si ce n'est plus en baisse est il
soutient plus le plan c 6 et donc on a
affaibli les casques bleus on affaiblit
casques blancs qu'on voit poser tout de
suite une qui travaillent
le coût des saints qui bien sûr affaibli
cette case voilà et ce coût a longtemps
fait peur au noir et en fait on
s'aperçoit que tu es noir une position
solide malgré tout malgré
l'affaiblissement de la case alors le
coup c'est 5 par exemple ici des 5 c 5
pour les noirs bon ça c'est pas bon ces
alertes en temps mais c'est pas bon se
joue à 5 blanc parlant à 5 ici et là
c'est embêtant parce qu'on menace à
prendre les six après mais s'est cassé
la figure de piolenc et si on joue faux
bessette évidemment en disant à prendre
les six tours prend faudra ça marche pas
parce qu'on joue à six on peut jouer à 6
way suivez le foot auxerre venir est
suivi de fougue et 5 par exemple pour
revenir fouler scène pour venir ainsi
dix cavaliers b 5 ans là c'est horrible
et ça fait très mal
oui voilà donc c'est donc à 5 et pénible
sur a5b prend à cinq quand même en
parler
il vous est donc ils ont peur de se
faire appliquer un plan puisque la dame
des huit protège et ben on a quand même
la possibilité de 1,2 ou est ce que je
propose dans la foulée 5 c'est bien avec
qui j'ai joué cavalier des deux
cavalières 3e carolis et 4 et france 5
avec une belle 15 ans ici arrivé voilà
donc clasico si cette manoeuvre très
connu qu'il faut pas jamais oublié dans
plein variant dans pleine ouverture on
croyait cette voiture type b donne
effectivement là des choses comme ça
bien sûr donc dont sur sur b6 des cinq
des 5 6 et 5 n'est pas bon signe pas
m'en fous 17 semble le bon notre joujou
bessette un jour où bessèges et en cas
de prisons groupe rendu fou avec bien
sûr un pion b6 un peu fermé protéger
quand même par le faux bessette et la
menace latente
d'abord d'abord la pression sur le point
4 et la menace latente pourquoi pas de
jouer dame ses huit dames bessette et
d'augmenter cette par exemple alors on
n'est pas pressé en plus avec les blancs
on n'est pas obligé de prendre tout de
suite là le coût théorique seydoux et b
3 et 3 avec l'idée floue à trois et on
veut jouer pour remettre la pression sur
le futur pions des six faible oui parce
que si on prend à ses six sa menace
rapion prince et six et il faut prendre
les six si lecavalier 17 noeuds n'a pas
bush l'a fait mais sur ses grands
desseins v5 avec les grands desseins et
la tour c 8 tours 6,8 avec une menace
stéphane ces deux de prendre en d5
on est 5 oui ou cavaliers prendre cavale
et prend plutôt grave elle vous prend
bien sûr et surtout prend et bien frais
fou prend des cinq messieurs hélas la
dame ne peut pas prendre des cinq la
corruption ces deux en l'air ouais voilà
pendant alors imaginons un coût 1 on va
dire comme h3 tout simplement parce
qu'elle a eu avec la réponse est simple
vous prend voilà vous prend dans prends
parce que scipion prend également si les
noirs sont contents puisque l'arrêt
place en fait il serait obligé de
s'interrompre ans le voilà le papa de
matériel mais sait il faut jamais mettre
deux pions sur les cases forte ici en d5
on avait une case forte
voilà parce que la durée tout reprend
ses deux et si on prend du plomb hors
dia plus de pions faible ici puisque on
n'attaque plus heleniak décembre gül
voilà donc ça va pas du tout et si on
prend avec la dame on perd le pion voilà
donc c'est pas bon donc tour s'est vite
menace cette variante est donc là on
joue un coup c'est pour ça qu'on a
expliqué tout ça parce que tour deux
heureux de la facile explique voilà leur
expliquer tourne autour d'eux maintenant
si tout est changé en d5 et bien on peut
reprendre avec la dame et garder notre
case bien sûr intéressante bien sûr
monsieur alors là on peut montrer
cavaliers c5 jouer puisque c'est
maintenant le curieux 81 soucis comme en
défense pions pas évident la dame peut
pas venir en d3 on est obligé d'éliminer
un attaquant et demi le khalife 500 on
enlève le cavalier de la classe forte
mais de l'autre côté puis c'est le fou
17 qui tape
voilà mais on va avoir une petite idée
pour le foot pro f 6 l'idée c'est de
l'échangé et la maintenance ou des
céréales a donc on va donc une position
conditions tout à fait tout à fait
tenable alors il ya quand même une
petite faiblesse en d6 dame 17 17
il faut à trois temps que lecavalier là
ce fou ne sert pas à grand chose
voilà et surtour des 8 par exemple de
coups illégaux ils mettent par exemple
est intéressant c'est de prendre assez
simple quand même des princes est simple
et tours d2 en attendait d'eux avec un
petit vis-à-vis un petit vis-à-vis et on
a aussi un rapport de pièces intéressant
c'est que on va échanger les fous de
cases blanches ne restera plus qu'une
pièce mineurs de chaque côté on va
échanger les fous le tour et peut-être
mètres la tour en dessins ouais et on va
surtout joué contre le mauvais food et
noir qui est le fou et f6 nouvelle fois
puisqu'il est sur la couleur des pions
bloqués et en tête d'abord ses cadres
d'avoir ces quatre cavaliers eu un
cavalier ces deux cavaliers ou trois ans
sur vos dires ils sont superbes ce
cavalli voilà donc la position est quand
même favorable aux blancs on a créé les
gens là tranquille je suis tranquille
avec des perspectives les noirs en ont
beaucoup moins un peu long comparé mais
tout à fait intéressant enfin tout quand
on venait de signer par une folle
repositionner la même
on va continuer à repositionner les
temps du choc on a fait le tour de cette
très belle variante fido un bon petit
tour de la fille leader alors pour les
pour les attaquants mais il ya ce coup
j'ai quatre là qui va vous plaire sans
doute oui ben bien sûr ce superbe coup
j'ai 4 il faut absolument le on va le
revoir
on va terminer là dessus quand même pour
ceux qui veulent pas s'embêter avec les
grandes arènes de l'afinitor très joli
coup gecas voilà à la shirokov c'est ça
non la même média rohff oui mais c'est
sûr qu'il s'échauffe qui l'a popularisé
popularisé à la classique honda ont
sacrifié un pion est ce qu'à y penser
quand on joue simplement tour g1 est sûr
qu'à mélancolie
on se développe tranquillement voilà
voilà cette idée tout simplement hop on
joue au petit à 3 ont fait le grand
roque et on n'a pas peur casse de prises
ici on simplifie howard est là et le
superbe fourrage 3 shiro viens on va
jouer fou des sept chèques avec une
partie très intéressante
voilà je voulais voir qui est préfère
jouer le jeu de position des autres
cases et bien vous avez avoir un teint
classique avec fous ces quatre fausses
et quatre petits rock taureau un qui est
une possibilité
alors je peux peut-être s'il ya
peut-être aussi une autre un autre
système qui peut être intéressant pour
ceux aussi qui veulent éviter des
grandes grandes variantes aussi
ah mais non c'était sur fion prendre des
cartes c'était autre chose j'avais
quatre ans quand des têtes on a donné
des idées
mais voilà donc que l'afinitor très
intéressant je crois qu'on a vu
l'ensemble des branches qui compte
je crois qu'il ya une variante aussi
quand les noirs jouent à celle justement
il n'y a pas une histoire de c est quand
même des choses comme ça ah il ya
beaucoup de variantes
en tout cas il ya rien de grave qu'on
aurait oublié ça c'est sûr et en fait on
est bien obligé de prendre des
directions des orientations dans des
ouvertures aussi vaste que la fille de
hand sur il peut pas tout voir puisque
nous donne des pistes 1 on vous rappelle
voilà on vous on vous explique le fonds
de l'ouverture oui mais avoue après 2
une fois que vous avez trouvé quelque
chose qui vous qui vous plaisait de se
spécialiser en regardant et en sus des
champions info rappeler quand même qu'il
ya plus de parties d'échecs possible que
d'atomes dans l'univers visible ce qui
fait un paquet quand même deux parties
c'est pas possible
si si c'est possible voilà merci jean
baptiste pour cette analyse de la
défense philidor sur diagonale tv leçon
merci de nous suivre sur des modèles tv
et puis je vous donne rendez-vous pour
une prochaine émission merci de nous
suivre et de nous être fidèles voilà au
revoir à voir